darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
rudis mir live zugeschaltet herr cerne
seit der letzten sendung von
aktenzeichen xy ist bekannt dass gegen
christian der jetzt ermittelt wird wie
war die resonanz auf die sendung ja es
gab damals 16 hinweise wo bei alfred
hackmann vom landeskriminalamt bayern
gesagt hat dass ein hinweis dabei sei
der durchaus zielführend sein könnte in
richtung dieser telefonnummer es geht ja
immer noch darum deswegen der auftritt
auch noch mal von christian hoppe dem
leitenden kriminaldirektor des
bundeskriminalamts explizit um diese
telefonnummer diese portugiesische
telefonnummer weil man da unbedingt
wissen will wer von dort aus angerufen
hat offensichtlich gibt es jetzt eine
möglichkeit könnte es eine möglichkeit
geben dass man den besitzer dieser
nummer ausfindig macht aber wie gesagt
das ist alles noch sehr vage
sie haben gerade gesagt es gab 16
hinweise sind das 16 hinweise die
hilfreich waren oder insgesamt haben 16
menschen irgendwelche tipps abgegeben um
dabei zu helfen dass der fall maddie
doch noch gelöst werden kann
es gab natürlich mehr anrufe zu diesem
fall oftmals rufen die menschen an um
ihr bedauern zum ausdruck zu bringen
oder ihre bestürzung zum ausdruck zu
bringen aber diese 16 hinweise werden
jetzt also vom bundeskriminalamt
beziehungsweise von den ermittlern
verschrifteten und jedem hinweis wird
man dann sehr sorgfältig nachgehen das
ist die vorgehensweise der polizei der
ermittler
werden sie in der kommenden sendung von
aktenzeichen xy noch einmal auf
christian b eingehen
wir werden sicherlich in der sendung am
august ist dann wieder eine reguläre
ausgabe von aktenzeichen xy da geht es
ausschließlich um ungelöste fälle unter
umständen noch mal auf christian b
eingehen oder auf den mit aktuellen
ermittlungsstand wir haben morgen in
unserer sendung ausschließlich gelöste
fälle drei gelöste fälle bei denen die
polizei wirklich über jahre hinweg in
einem fall fast zwei jahrzehnte in süßen
fußarbeit diese fälle wirklich lösen
konnte wir werden zusammen mit lydia
benecke das ist eine kriminalpsychologin
die psyche der täter auch mal erläutern
da geht es um wirklich ganz ganz
schlimme vorfälle
wir schauen auch auf die
ermittlungsarbeit der kriminalbeamten
wir wissen dass das die zuschauer immer
sehr gerne wissen wollen
glauben sie selber denn das der fall
maddie jetzt gelöst werden kann
naja ich hoffe dass der fall gelöst
werden kann meine aktuelle
informationsstand ist der dass es noch
keinen dringenden tatverdacht gibt es
gegen christian b es gibt einen
tatverdacht aber es fehlen nach wie vor
ort das müsse noch immer wieder
festhalten beweise es fehlt eine leiche
aber es gibt da jetzt diese diese neuen
ermittlungsansätze der ermittler aus
portugal
dann nämlich in der nähe des ortes praia
da luz wo von von dort aus mittelmeer
kennen verschwunden
diese drei bewässerungs brunnen jetzt
untersucht werden mehrere polizeibeamte
waren vor ort und wir sind sehr gespannt
auf das ergebnis